The Santa Claus we see today with his jolly belly,...
...white beard, and sleigh has actually been inspired by many great people in our history,...
...the most popular being Saint Nicholas.
A nobleman born in Greece,...
...Nicholas was born to wealthy parents in the village of Patara.
After his parents died, he decided to sell what he owned,...
...give the money to the poor, and devote his life to God.
Devoting his life to help the needy earned him the honor of becoming the Bishop of Myra.
One of his most famous good works was his secret network designed to help the poor children.
These and many more are attributes of Saint Nicholas...
...that can be seen in the present day story of Santa Claus.